my quail is chasing a drugs epidemic
across Kentucky right now we're being
sent on a male who has overdosed in
Louisville in January alone there were
695 overdose cases that's a 33 percent
rise from last year many from heroin and
prescription drugs might fear this could
be another we hear him working inside ok
few problems ventilating see is their
paraphernalia in here yeah ok
this is a race against time and it's a
coordinated response inside there are
police the fire brigade and paramedics
and they're trying to resuscitate the
man minutes later progress so he's
breathing on his own ok he's still it's
kind of a term that we use he's still
snowed and that's kind of how we want to
keep him and when they get him in the
back of the truck you know they're gonna
give him more and wake him up even more
suddenly he appears on a stretcher his
face drawn and pale it's mid-afternoon
by a busy road I come from a small town
in South Washington Donald Trump is
listening unveiling a new task force to
tackle the deadliest drugs crisis a u.s.
history of drug overdoses are now the
leading cause of accidental death in our
country and opioid overdose deaths have
nearly quadrupled since 1999 this is a
total epidemic
it's playing out in car parks and
affluent suburbs they're getting dirty
needles from her but taking pills
passing out in the bathroom anywhere
where you can get high and where you
feel safe that's where they going you
were getting way over prescribed
Elizabeth Easton it started two decades
ago with oxycontin a prescription
painkiller I thought it was very very
safe that's and I quit drinking I quit
smoking marijuana I went right to that I
thought it was safe my grades improved I
thought I felt that I had improved by
taking that drug it was like to me it
was like a miracle drug yeah and it
wasn't it was synthetic heroin so this
is our but at this new clinic one drug
is opening doors for addicts after detox
it's called vivitrol it actually blocks
opiate receptors it stops you feeling
the high yes you don't get the euphoria
that you would from heroin or any
opioids like hydrocodone oxycodone
schedule two it's not a silver bullet
but for Ryan and his mother it's hope
you know I asked him every day how do
you feel how do you feel you know I'm
hoping with the intensive outpatient
treatment that he's doing and that he
continues the injection that he'll get
to a point where he feels he doesn't
need that anymore and he'll get a job
and he'll have a normal life the
president is now working on a plan tens
of thousands of lives could depend on it
in a nation with too many pills and not
enough treatment
Hadiya Lynch Sky News Louisville
Kentucky